non
les armes c'est facile volonté
vous prendre ça vous allez enveloppe
avec oui je suis pas sûr
oui j'ai 100 temps passé sans de joie je
ne fais pas très attention au visage
mais je suis né en 1918 mais quand vous
faites pour garder la forme à votre âge
oriel bien vous êtes un petit secret
pour moi sommes en jeu et on s'est tous
bien 5quels 6 et 8 hors auto et caveaux
je crois bien travaillé tu m'as bien
voir du monde il était resté six mois
qu'il attend de gagner j'en passe elle
c'est henriette ardouin et pendant ce
temps là à bagnères de luchon
celle qu'on appelle ici madame alix
quand le nom de son magasin travaille
toujours
vous travaillez tous les jours tous les
shows et je suis jamais fatigué j'ai la
santé c'est sa hauteur et j'aurai la
santé je travaille quand cette boutique
dans laquelle elle travaille depuis 1948
henriette devant ces photos et des
cartes postales et pour cette centenaire
célibataire ce magasin c'est la vie
c'est ma vie c'est tout
j'aime les clients paieront en temps je
trouve que quand et rentre chez world
c'est agréable bonne journée
mais combien je dois en 81
voilà bien 6,5 aventure et laurie leurs
locaux
ll augmenter leur taux très bien elle
est polyglotte set je vis de vous avoir
rencontré ici c'est la réserve ses
lasers 10 15 personnes et alors oui mais
qu'un portable des photos j'ai des
photos donnent tout pour bien des jets
la montagne c'est joli ça y est c'est
vous qui avez fait ces photos
bah oui je suis photographe mais j'ai
jamais fait un point si sage voilà on
assiste à cette époque c'était
d'appareils professionnelle computer
salah et faisait la photo oui ont
toujours su m'en servir parce que
j'étais à vis à la photo professionnelle
ça se fait plus vous allez continuer à
travailler jusqu'à quand on va se passer
quelques unes mais vous voulez continuer
jusqu'à cambrai awoingt portugais
continue tant que j'ai la santé
cap la santé multi troll je quitterais
aussi la musique est peut-être ils ont
toujours ses amis
[Musique]